a new wildfire outbreak in northern
california has turned deadly at least
three people were killed in the zog fire
it's called
burning about 150 miles north of
sacramento nearly 70 000 people have
been told to leave their homes in the
wine country north of san francisco
where the glass fire combined with two
others just yesterday
the flames have burned more than 50
square miles leaving parts of the area
looking well like
mars jonathan bigliotti is in napa
county
with more on this story
good morning to you you're looking at
yet another home that is about to go
up in flames the fire has destroyed more
than a hundred structures at this hour
as it continues to push its way
down the mountainside into neighborhoods
nearly 70 thousand people have been
evacuated
the fire stands at zero percent
containment
as it continues to grow
the glass incident fire tore through
napa and sonoma counties monday
consuming a decades-old winery and a
popular bed and breakfast
it damaged the grounds that the elite
meadow would resort
while leaving entire neighborhoods in
ruins
evacuees say they had little time to
outrun the flames
as it grew to tens of thousands of acres
a lot of explosions flames everywhere as
you were escaping
yes the conditions here are so dry it is
like a tinderbox and these flames are
getting
dangerously close to neighborhoods the
fire forced members of this retirement
community
home to more than 4 500 seniors to
evacuate
it covered cars with ash and turned the
skies above sonoma county red
as the smoke blocked the sun another
beautiful day in the napa valley
just unbelievable so far this year
california has seen more than 8 thousand
wildfires
destroying more than 7 thousand
buildings
scorching nearly 5 800 square miles
that's the size of almost 3 million
football fields
29 people have died
three of those deaths came monday as the
zog fire
some 300 miles to the north grew to 15
thousand
acres and those victims have not been
identified the california governor has
declared a state of emergency
in three counties including here in napa
county and the weather conditions are
not going to improve it's going to be
hot
and dry for much of the week back to you
more trouble ahead jonathan thank you